TODAY THAT CHINA HAS BEEN
RIPPING OFF THE U.S.
THE PRESIDENT HAD CHOICE WORDS
FOR A LOT OF PEOPLE TONIGHT.
>> President Trump: CHINA HAS
BECOME VERY SPOILED.
THE EUROPEAN UNION HAS BECOME
VERY SPOILED.
OTHER COUNTRIES HAVE BECOME VERY
SPOILED.
THEY ALWAYS HAVE 100% OF
WHATEVER THEY WANTED FROM THE
UNITED STATES.
WE CAN'T ALLOW THAT TO HAPPEN
ANYMORE.
>> Reporter: JUST AS THE
SECOND ROUND OF TRADE TALKS GOT
UNDERWAY, PRESIDENT TRUMP TOOK'S
AIM AT BEIJING'S THING THE
CHINESE CAN AND SHOULD CUT
MILLIONS FROM THEIR TRADE
SURPLUS FROM THE U.S.
B-2 WE HAVE BEEN RIPPED OFF BY
CHINA, AND EVACUATION OF WEALTH
LIKE NO COUNTRY HAS EVER SEEN
BEFORE.
>> Reporter: AMONG THE
NEGOTIATIONS, THE TREASURY OF
COMMERCE, THE PRESIDENT'S CHIEF
ECONOMIC ADVISOR AND A PAIR OF
TRADE OFFICIALS INCLUDING PETER
NAVARRO WHO AUTHORED THE
BEST-SELLING BOOK, "DEATH BY
CHINA" WHICH IS SAID TO HAVE
UPSET SOME CHINESE NEGOTIATORS.
FOR THE PRESIDENT, A STEADY
BARRAGE OF TWEETS UNDERSCORED
HIS POSITION THAT QUOTE THE U.S.
HAS VERY LITTLE TO GIVE BECAUSE
IT HAS GIVEN SO MUCH OVER THE
YEARS."
AFTER THREATENING TO SET ITS
SIGHTS ON NEW TARIFFS FOR
AIRCRAFT'S, SOYBEANS AND AUTO
IMPORTS, BEIJING APPEARS TO HAVE
RELENTED.
WHEN THE PRESIDENT ASKED THE
COMMERCE DEPARTMENT TO TAKE A
FRESH LOOK AT RESTRICTIONS THAT
CRIPPLED THE CHINESE TELECOM
GIANT, ZTE.
CRITICS HAVE WARNED OF THE
PRESIDENT'S AGGRESSIVE TRADE
TACTICS COULD SPARK A GLOBAL
TRADE WAR WITH CHINA, E.U.,
NAFTA PARTNERS, CANADA, MEXICO
AND EVEN JAPAN ALL THREATENING
TO IMPLEMENT NEW TARIFFS ON THE
U.S.
TOKYO ALONE SENT TO IMPOSE
LEVIES WORTH ABOUT $900 MILLION.
>> President Trump: TRADE HAS
BEEN A TOTAL ONE-WAY STREET.
YOU TAKE MONEY OUT BY THE BUCKET
LOADS.
I COULD NAME ALMOST EVERY SINGLE
COUNTRY IN THE WORLD, WE HAD NO
ONE REPRESENTING US.
AND NOW, YOU HAVE SOMEONE WHO IS
VERY GOOD AT THIS STUFF, MEAN
COMP REPRESENTATIVES.
>> ASKED IF HE THOUGHT THE TALKS
WOULD END WILL COME AT THE